so we've known each other like a month
now we've been on a couple dates
yeah just sex kind of dates I think so
so like that's fair five or six days I
feel like we do we've done this thing
where we've gotten drunk and we have
like these deep life talks but then I
don't remember any of the next dates you
have to like retrace the steps again I
know you're a DJ right you got that from
boström yep nailed it
what do you know about me you are from
New York good start you in the New York
all right Florida then you think the
BuzzFeed thing that's it that's all you
know allow me what's my favorite food
have we talked about this a lot the
reason we don't really know each other
but we've got a few dates it's nice
you're not a serial killer that I know
of yet yeah
if you find something surprising like
I'll probably be surprised too I'm
nervous that I won't be able to remember
why I searched something all right
good wine a coke oh yeah that's great
yeah we both like to drink a lot why are
you looking at prices of for vets
bowling alley cost so we were okay you
like [ __ ] loaded and I don't know it
Sergent Corvettes and bowling alley
I mean curious about it the Cure la that
may or may not be a service that comes
to your house and gives you an IV drip
you stairs oh [ __ ] 3:00 in the
morning drinking whiskey on a [ __ ]
work night there's a door boys you just
pay a couple bucks cause then they
caught me doing it 45 minutes gonna do
screws here for you for you cut your
cabinet right yeah you help me install
shelves through how does a great move to
get laid what is the Coors Light some
apple jack also great alcohol
how to wear a tux do you not know how to
wear I've done well I wore a tux the
first time in a long time I got my own
tux did I maybe there's some others like
confidence tips like how to wear this
[ __ ] no need to when I do things I do it
proper I got in French cuffs shirts and
never wore those before I thought was
supposed to wear on the outside kind of
like a pirate or something and I really
that's definitely not what you do if you
just Google pictures of tuxes good times
Co it said good times Thank You Kelsey I
love good times I don't know what that
is why not jeez your shipment is
confirmed seven good times
well I have like a whole joy of sex toys
you've seen Matt haven't you I haven't
this extra good times it sounds like it
was a shot I thought it was the bar you
want to know I know we're gonna be great
together how to clean wine glasses
properly get you a man who googles that
can't go wrong with this girl I gotta
figure how do you do it so I thought it
was just water and you actually can use
soap to you want to get drinks after
that yeah actually I feel like I could
just pull up my last porn search history
and that's a thing that the search is oh
you just said [ __ ] hot I just knew
that I wanted to be [ __ ] about that
is amazing all the days right okay my
play you feel like he wasn't that
exciting I thought it's gonna be a lot
more interesting it's kind of pretty
Taemin nothing I saw made me want to go
I like don't wanna hang out with you
again
[Music]